nordvpnがスポンサーとなっている今日のビデオでみんながここに
います。以下のリンクで詳細をご覧ください。このビデオ
の主なテーマの1つである日本を現在どのように勉強しているかについて話します。
日本人を学ぼうとしている他の外国人のスピーチに自分自身をさらすのではなく、できるだけ多くのネイティブスピーチに自分自身をさらすイマージョンを信じる私は、
イマージョンベースのアプローチが
本質的にすべての学習者にとってはるかに効果的だと思います
学習プロセスの
4つの異なる分野私は読む
ことを書くことを聞くことと話すことを私
がカバーするのが好きだと思うので、すぐに飛び込ん
で、過去の読書について話しましょう
iiが取ったアプローチはankiアプリを使用すること
でし
た
できるだけ多くの新しい単語を学び、
それを日本の文学の本を読むことと組み合わせると、
小説ができます。
私が何年にもわたって読んだ主な作家
はおそらく
金原
であり、村上春樹もたくさん読んだことがあり
ますが、私は
マートル神原王の大ファンではありません。
日本語を学び始めたら読ま
なくてはいけないと言っていますが、村上
さんが
書いた小説のオーディションに基づいた日本の映画のオーディションが
好きです。
ある
レベルでは、自分に挑戦するコンテンツを積極的に探し始める必要があります。通常の社会のように
設定された小説は
、この時点ではもうそれほど挑戦的ではありません。
新しい挑戦方法を見つけるために。 自分自身
と新しい単語や
新しい文法構造に自分自身をさらす新しい
文体やそのようなもの私は実際に
小説から少し逸脱して、より具体的な分野に入る必要があり
ます。たとえば、最近読んだ
これは建築に関する本
です。理由の1つは、私が実際に日本で家を建てていることです。
それを超えて
、実際に
これらの種類のjlpt準備本は
すべてええと
特別な準備本です。  n1のリーディング
セクションは
、高レベルの日本語を維持するのに非常に役立ちます。その理由
は、
さまざまなトピックをカバーしているためです。これらはすべて、
間違いなくそのn1レベルで
あり、非常に多くの異なるトピックで書かれているためです。
スタイル
この本に書かれているエッセイのいくつかは意見の
断片ですそれらのいくつかは
イベントのはるかに客観的な種類の説明
ですそれらのいくつかは前後に2つの意見で
あり、あなたは
1人の著者が何であるかを理解する必要があります
他の著者が何を言っているのか、どこで重なっているのかなどを
知るこれらの本のもう1つの素晴らしい点は
、そのレベルに達すると、
エコノムなどのさまざまな主題について学ぶことができること
です。  icsと日本語の経済学に関するさまざまな見解です
が、これらの本を読むだけで、私の
友人の規範は、
私たちが約2
年前に東京レンズから行った規範であるビデオ
で言いたい素晴らしい引用をしまし
た。 私
は、これらの本で毎日1ページ分の運動を1ページ分
行うようにしています。通常、昼休みにそれを積極的に行わず
、日常の日本語の種類を超えている場合は、
確かにあなたの日本人の声を
読んでください。 能力は低下し始めますそれは
少なくとも私が
見つけたものですので、これらの本は
特定のレベルを維持するのに最適ですそしてもちろん
あなたが実際にそれを取り入れたい
と思っていてあなたがこのような本を読んで
それをやっているなら
一日に1、2回のエクササイズは素晴らしい
位置
にいるので、私の仕事はスクリプトを作成することなので、私の仕事で書く練習をしていると想像する人が多いので、それはおそらく読書のセクションに適していると思います。
j
毎日ではないにしても、おそらく少なくとも隔日で日本語のアパネスコメディスクリプト
私は日本語で何かを書いていますそして
iiスクリプトはそれらすべてのビデオであり、通常
何が起こるかは
おそらく他のすべてのビデオです
これで
十分だ
と思います。ジョークはまだ自動です
。日本の視聴者は
これを理解し、おそらくそれをくすくす笑いますが、
これはこのアイデアを表現するための絶対的な最良の方法
です。 このように
、同じ行を2つか
3つの異なる方法で準備します。なぜなら
、英語でも私の母国語
には
、1つのアイデアを表現するための数十、数十、数十の異なる方法が常にあるから
です
。 両方のオプションを書き留めてから
、ネイティブ
スピーカーに相談します。
これは
あなたにとってより自然に感じますか？これはあなたにとってより自然に感じます
か
？ 彼ら
はあなたにとって違うと感じますか、それともまったく同じように感じますか？
そのフィードバックに基づいて、
どのラインを使うかを決定
します。これは私にとって本当に素晴らしいこと
です。 古い
コンテンツ私が苦労したこれらのポイントの1つに
遭遇し、それらの
ポイントを確認し、それらのポイントに対する答えの種類を確認することもできます私は苦労したことを見ることができ
ます答えを見る
そしてその経験から成長する私
は、可能な限り簡単な方法でアイデアを表現しようとするジョージ・
オーウェルの
アプローチがとても好きです。
意図的にn1文法のようなものをたくさん使って、
自分を賢く聞こえるようにしますが、
これは常に裏目
に出て、特にコメディーに関して
は、考えを伝えるために可能な限り最も単純な言語を使用することが最善であることがわかりました。
3つの
リスニングi このビデオの冒頭でこれについて触れたと思い
ますが、レベルに関係なく
、日本語を上達させるためにできる最善のことは
、できるだけ多くのネイティブスピーチを聞くことだと強く
信じています。 なぜなら
、あなたが教室で日本語を学んで
いて、
あなたがまた勉強している他の科目の完全なカリキュラムを持っているなら
、あなたが聞く日本語のかなりの量は、ネイティブスピーチではなく
日本語を話そうとしている他の外国人かもしれません
そして明らかに
、あなたが聞いている日本語の半分が
ネイティブ日本語ではない場合、それは
ネイティブのようなアクセントを開発しようとするのに適してい
ません。また、日本語を使用して
自分自身を
表現し、日本人のネイティブスピーカーがするようにあなたの考えを明確に表現します
か？ 自分の考えを英語から日本語に
翻訳しようとしている人とは対照的に、
それ
は私の友人のマット対と思う別の主題です s日本
はおそらく
私よりもうまく故障する可能性が
ありますが、レベルに関係なく
、日本語を上達させるためにできる最善のこと
は、できるだけ多くのネイティブ日本語を聞く
ことです。これは私にも当てはまります。
ただ聞くことはできません。
私の日本語はネイティブレベルではないので、ビデオをドーガンして、日本語がネイティブ
レベルになることを期待します。レベルに関係なく、また私の
特定の状況に関しては、
読書の場合と同じように、できるだけ多くのネイティブコンテンツをもう一度聞いてください。 日本の日常生活は、日本の日常生活
で聞く日本語のレベルでは十分ではなく、
おそらくn1レベルではなくn2
レベルであり、これはかなりの
数の人にも
当てはまります。ほとんどのyoutubeコンテンツほとんどの
日本のyoutubeコンテンツ
そして、再び非常に高いレベルに到達し、
そのレベルを維持したい場合、
これは積極的に外に出
て、もう少し具体的なものを探すことを意味
します。
過去に
、タイタンへの攻撃を見ることは、実際
に私にとって本当に本当に良いことについて話しました。それ
は、塹壕を
意味するザンゴや、一種の防御基地を意味する
ヨルサイなど、戦争に関連する多くの単語を学ぶことができるからです。 そのようなもの、または
多分カンタイは艦隊の艦隊を意味すると私は信じてい
ますそれは正しい言葉だと思います
それは正しい言葉で安全でし
た 積極的に外に出
て、もう少しニッチな新しいコンテンツを見つけ
、
特定の軌道を
探索して、積極的に検索しない限り公開されない新しい単語をピックアップできるようにします。
この時点でタイタンへの攻撃を見たことがありますが、おそらく
文字通りシーズン全体の20倍近くです。この時点
で20回見たことがありますが、
最近
それから切り替えて、現在は再戦してい
ます。 日本の主要なストリーミングプラットフォームの
1つで最近リリースされた今までで一番好きなアニメである
アッチングモンスター。これは今日のスポンサーに叫びたい場所です。それは、
よくモンスターがどこで入手できるかという理由から
です。 私はすでにお金を払って
いるこれらの主要なストリーミングプラットフォームの1つで日本に
いますが、同じプラットフォームでは視聴できないテレビ番組がたくさんあります。これらは
地域でロックされているため、多くのテレビ番組や
アニメ、そして間違いなく傑作です。
私のようなオタクなら
誰でも私が見ることができないことを知っている映画。
私は日本にいるので、これは
今日のビデオnordvpnのスポンサーが、テレビ番組やYouTubeや字幕のオプションについて
話しているかどうかに関係なく参加する場所です。
表示されるストリーミング
プラットフォーム
は、多くの
場合、住んでいる地域に完全に依存しています
。vpnを知らない人は、
基本的に、
インターネット接続とmakを保護するために使用できるソフトウェアです。
人々
があなたをスパイしていないことを確認するだけでなく
、あなたのコンピュータをだましてあなたのインターネット
接続をあなたのインターネットプロバイダーに
あなたが別の地域にいると
思わせる
ので、セットアップをインストールして使用するのが非常に簡単な
nordvpnを使用できます
私が支払っているストリーミングサービスの可能性を解き放ち
、そのストリーミングサービスが日本国外でサポートしているすべてのコンテンツを表示
します。nordvpnは
VPN分野のリーダーの1つであり
、簡単に安全で利用できるアプリがあります
。 すべての主要なプラットフォームの
接続は高速で信頼性が高く
、60か国の5100を超えるサーバーでコンテンツをストリーミングする場合は明らかに重要
です。1つのアカウントで最大
6つのデバイスを同時に接続できます。これは
、次のようなユーザーに最適です。
妻が
ストリーミングサービスで何かを見ている間、私のストリーミングサービスで1つのことをよく見ている私
は、今すぐ下のリンクでnordvpn.comdoganにアクセス
して 2年間の1か月プラン
を大幅に割引し
ます。また、このビデオを後援してくれたnordvpnにも感謝します。
ここに家を建てているため、現在非常に厳しい財政状況にあるため、心から感謝しています。
銀行は私たちを台無しにして
しまいました。これは将来の10種類のビデオで
、家が完成したら楽しいものになりますが、
それは本当に役に立ち
ます。皆さんがサービスの恩恵を受けられることを願っています。
-状況に
勝ち、以下の説明のリンクを使用してnordvpnをもう一度チェックしてください。
このビデオの最後の側面をカバーしましょう。
日本語のスピーキング要素は、
おそらく
2つのセクションがあると思います。そのため、1つは
あなたの考えと会話を明確に表現します。
コミュニケーションともう一つは
、あなたが
作っている音が自然に聞こえるかどうかで
あり、コミュニケーションに関しては
、conの自然な出力の鍵だと思います
書面
とは対照的な会話が
入力される自然な出力の鍵
は、ドラマやアニメで知っている
か、実際の生活でどこに
いても、ネイティブスピーチを常に聞いているときは、常にネイティブ入力です。 あなたはいつもそれをやっていて
、日本の文法の基本的な理解と、おそらく
日本の会話で最も一般的な500または1000の単語を
持っています毎日のスピーチあなたは自然な方法で
あなたの考えを明確にすることを自然に学びます
が、
自然な発音と高低アクセントの
発音にもっと集中したい
ので、現在どのようにこれら2つのことを勉強している
ので、多くの人がおそらく
知っているように、私は日本の発音
と高低アクセントのようなイントネーションも教えて
いますが、多くの人は
パトレオンのイントネーションと、あそこに投稿するレッスンの
内容の圧倒的大部分は、
私が直接学んだこと
です。 留学
中にコ大学で受けた高低アクセントコースです
が
、
実地調査もたくさんありますので
、訓練を受けたネイティブスピーカーとかなりの量のネイティブスピーカーと
話をします。 それはnhkアカデミーを通過し、
当然私
は多くの情報を再確認し、これらの本のいくつかを
使用して追加の調査を試みるので
、これらのさまざまなリソースを簡単に分析する良い機会になると思いました。
過去に私のビデオで見た
ことがあるので、
ここに日本語の発音と高低アクセントに関する18冊の本があります。
これらの1つは、実際に
は、その集中的なハッスルコースからの留学からの配布物の1つ
です。 私はコ大学でこれを見るのは
面白いです
が、明らかにあなたたちはこれを買うことができない
ので、
最初に次のリソースに進みます私たちはnihongonihを持ってい
ます オンゴアクセント
日本語アクセントの紹介
これは日本語ベースのリソースですが、すでに日本語
を読むのが得意で
、高低アクセントについて学び
たいが、表や単語リストが
苦手な場合は非常に便利です。
わかりやすく、
アクセント
辞書であるnhkアクセント辞書とシマカアクセント辞書の両方とは対照的に、簡単な言語で物事を説明する仕事は、
はるかに徹底的ですが
、言語は
これらを理解するのがはるかに困難です 日本語で
もテーブルもたくさんあり、単語リストもたくさんあり
ます。
これらのuhの本でも、もっと技術的な言葉を言う
と思います。一般的に、nhk
はもう少しアクセスしやすいの
に対し、shimakai
は少し難しいと思います。
でももう少し徹底的になりまし
たうつこし
[音楽]
この本はもっと
高低アクセントではなく、高低アクセントについてたくさんあります
この本も同様です
が、
日本語の高低アクセントを学ぼうとしている外国人ではなく、改善
したい日本人を対象とした、ある種の魅力的な話し方について、ほとんど口述のように言います。
彼ら自身の日本語は
かなり古いですが、私はこの本から多くを学びました。
実際にこれらの本のいくつかをスキップするつもりです。
なぜなら、これらのいくつかは
おそらく
このビデオを見ているほとんどの人にとって少し進んでいると思うからです。
ええと、このリストにはおそらく
2、3冊の追加の本がありますが、
この1つがこのうーんであると、人々は本当に恩恵を受けることができると思います。
音韻論を教えること
も日本のリソースですが、これは
高低アクセントだけでなく、素晴らしいリソースです。 しかし、ほとんどの場合
、高低アクセントよりも発音が多く、リズムが好きですが、高低アクセントも
カバーしています。
自然に聞こえます。
日本語ですが、これは
日本人学習者
が日本語のパートナーのために購入すること
をお勧めする一番のリソースです。日本語のパートナーに
これを購入してもらうか、
これを読んでもらい、読んでもらいます。
この本全体
を1時間ほどで読むことができれば、
日本語
の発音の問題点をすぐに明確に表現
し、ある程度までより多くの
発音を提案することができますが、これは本当に
日本人に
発音の問題を
認識させ、それらの問題を修正する方法を見つけるのに適しています。
私が簡単に話したかった他の2つの主なリソース
は、これらは
drvanceによる日本語の音とlebronによる日本語の音声学です。
日本語の発音と
ピッチアクセントのすべてについて信じられないほど詳細な素晴らしいリソースええと、
私はそれらが2つのシングルだと思います
日本の発音と
英語の高低アクセントについて学ぶためのすべてを学ぶための最高の本これは少し新しい
ですこの
本はかなりの量を参照していますが
、ほとんどの人にとって大きな違い
はアクセシビリティだと思います
つまり、dr vance
は、言語学の
バックグラウンドが
なく、
音韻論や言語学を
まったく勉強したことがない人に、物事を分解する前に、物事を説明するのにより良い仕事をしていると思います。
初めは
、その分野の経験がない人にとっては少し読みやすい
です。日本人の音韻論は
新しいと思いますが、もう少し徹底的かもしれませんが、
これは
もう少し難しいと思います 言語学について
すでにかなりの量を知っているなら
、この本はおそらくより良いでしょうが、この本は
、あなたがそのfiを勉強したことがないなら、あなたが一度も行ったことがないなら、よりアクセスしやすいです
これは、
日本の言語学の紹介です。
これは、発音と給料
だけでなく、日本の言語学に関する優れた総合
的な本です。もちろん、発音とピッチアクションについても説明しています。
日本の言語学の側面ですが、日本の言語学の他の
部分や
日本の文法などもあるので
、この
本はすべての日本の言語学のワンストップ
ショップのよう
なものです。
あなたたちが以前に私の棚で見た本、
そしてあなたたちの誰かが
これらの本の内容について疑問に思っているなら、あなたが今それらについてもう少し知っていることを願っています
そしてもちろん
私がちょうど
それらをリンクすることをお勧めしたこれらのリソース 以下
の説明の日本のピッチアクセントの
私の全体の書誌でも同様ですが、
それはおそらくこのビデオにとっても良いことだ
と思います 持ち帰りのポイント
は、レベルに関係なく日本語を上達させるためにできる唯一の最善のことは、このビデオ
を後援してくれたnordvpnのおかげで、できるだけ多くのネイティブ日本語を聞くことだと強く信じて
います。
サービス大丈夫
あなたたちとすぐにまた話してください
[音楽]
あなた